All right. Well, I can't believe I'm about to tell this story. You go, Oh God,
I don't even remember how old I was. This is easy. It was, it was, I remember,
I don't remember exactly how old it was,
but it was around that age as a teenager. When you first discovered porn, right?
Anyway, between life, I don't know, 13 to 15, something like that.
Maybe even early for some people, I don't know, but a pebble what it was to,
I think it was legitimately the first time I watched like a hand tie on my
computer. Right. And you went straight to hand-tight even watch it.
This was like, this was like, not long after I discovered porn.
He quickly got down that rabbit hole. Yeah, no like that,
that first time I hit the first time with him,
Ty was a different story and I was in my room and like, my room has like,
had a lock on it. Sorry. I thought I blocked the door. Oh,
Oh. And my thought. And I remember, I remember as well, we chant, I was,
it was a commercial Collegeville, Kalamazoo. Oh, classic classic. Right.
Classic. It's like next to libel black classic. Right. And uh,
and yeah, so I was like, Oh, something has a Rosen in me.
[inaudible] right. My, my little Joey has, has woke now. Right.
So I was like, let's give it a go. And so I did it. And then, uh,
I hear like a,
a clock of the door opening and I had looked around and it's my dad standing
there. He's pretty, he's pretty proud of you there. Oh,
he looked at me and he looked at what was on my screen and he looked at me again
and he just said really mad.
That seems like the most Australian man alive. He just said, I remember exactly.
Wait, what'd he say, he's like, really mate couldn't have been regular.
I wouldn't, I wouldn't even be disappointed with you. It was just regular porn.
And I was like, I mean, I've been past that point.
I was kind of we've experimented. And he's like, all right, whatever. Like,
I don't know why. I don't know what had,
I have already gotten bored of regular porn. I'm seeking new adventures.
I could legitimately see the very moment where the disappointment came.
You know what I mean? It's like, it's like,
it's like a certain look in my dad's eyes where it kind of went from like, Whoa,
what are you doing to, Oh, no, he's into that. He's into that.
Huh? Oh yes. Father. I am into that. Oh, you winning
[inaudible] and now I talk about it for a job. So yeah.
I hope you're proud of me, dad, that felt so desperate.
Please love me please. I'm winning now.
I'm finally winning dad. It's just that that moment is carved into you.
And you're like, you're like the son who just looks for your dad's approval.
I don't have a lot of like distinct memories during my childhood,
but that was definitely one that will like forever stick with me.
Like I it's kind of just implanted itself into the back of my brain. Yeah.
Now I don't know.
I've I've never been caught jacking off at all because to me it's like, if,
if I do this, a checklist happens 100 for me. It's it's,
it's, it's the same one. My snake. Unfortunately, it's it's the same one.
You know, you leave the house and you have your okay. Pat keys, wallet, phone,
same thing. Same thing. When, when you do the same thing, same thing, you know,
you do, you do the deed and you just like ahead door locks,
headphones on or whatever. Make sure nobody's in the house or nobody can hear.
And then you start see it with the lock on my door.
I got a little too overconfident. So I'm like, yeah, this is this full proof.
Isn't it. And then I just, I guess I just forgot, you know, what it felt like,
it felt like, you know,
when you're playing Pokemon and you like go into a cave and you put repel on and
it runs out just before, you're about to leave and you get into an encounter.
That's what it felt like. I was like, I wasn't that close,
but I don't know. Like, I've like, I thought getting walked in on.
Right? Yeah. It's like a common thing. Cause you see it so much on the internet.
Right. It's like, I go, like, what do I do? You know, that kind of stuff.
So have you ever walked in on anyone or been walked in on? Oh my gosh.
Maybe I have, I don't know. I feel like these are like buried memories. Yeah.
That's pretty a good chance. I've pretty walked. I dunno.
I've been to parties and seen, but like people just don't care.
They're just like having like a private time, you know? No,
I don't think I have actually, no. Yeah. I,
I think I've never walked in on someone,
but the closest I've come is it was union university. You know, it was, uh,
visiting a mate and it was like a group house.
So like two or three of them mate. So there,
and we were getting ready for the night out.
So I was just like saying hello to everyone. And then, um, I knock on this,
I knock on one of my mates door and I, you know,
that panic scramble that you can hear. So there's doors locked. Right. But I,
I knocked on the door and all I heard was
what I was doing. Honestly, that's all I heard. Right.
And then he opens the door and the laptop, which is opposites,
like where the door is, is conveniently closed. So I'm just like,
Oh, he's just doing. And it was like nothing. I was just, uh,
just working on my presentation, you know,
but I've never actually walked in on anyone,
but I feel like it's more common in America because in university there,
if you share a room that's, this is why I can't imagine weird to me.
This is why I can't imagine having a roommate. Right. Because how would you,
how would you schedule that? Anyone in America? Can you ask me, do you guys,
do you actually have to schedule your sessions?
Because when do you have to be like, where are you going?
How long will you be out legend coming back, urban legend.
Where do you tell each other? Where do you like Gigi?
Do you like have like a calendar where you schedule it? Okay guys. Okay.
So this, this time is my time. There's going to be a sock on the door.
That's how you know, and if the sock is on the door,
then it is like code red. Don't come in. Never me during my time.